nous venons donc de dévoiler une toute nouvelle statue à l'
extérieur de
notre nouveau centre ouest, qui est le bâtiment le
plus récent et le plus
vert de winchester et nous le considérons comme
une
représentation vraiment appropriée de ce qu'est un bâtiment vert
et de notre engagement envers la
durabilité et la justice sociale en tant que
université
il y a deux raisons pour lesquelles nous pensons que greta
est vraiment
digne d'une statue et pourquoi nous sommes si
heureux de dévoiler cette statue
aujourd'hui
la première est qu'elle est une jeune personne
qui a surmonté
ses propres défis personnels pour défendre
ce en quoi elle croit
et d'être une voix si largement
reconnue dans le monde
et c'est un message que nous
apprécions vraiment et que nous pensons être vraiment
important pour nos étudiants
et pour les jeunes deuxièmement greta est-
ce que vous connaissez un défenseur de la crise climatique
et de ce qui doit  être fait et nous nous y
engageons en tant qu'université,
donc deux deux raisons pour lesquelles nous pensons que c'est une
statue vraiment importante,
nous comprenons qu'il y a eu des
inquiétudes quant à la façon dont t  a statue a été financée
c'est l'une des touches finales du
nouveau développement du centre-ville ouest
sur le campus universitaire et
une petite partie de ce budget était une
clôture pour les
œuvres d'art, nous restons attachés comme jamais au
soutien des étudiants et dépensons des millions chaque
année pour le bien-être des étudiants et  soutenir
aucun financement pour cela ou aucun financement pour le
personnel n'a été affecté
par cette statue, donc la statue est
installée et dévoilée aujourd'hui
comme l'une des touches finales de ce
tout nouveau
bâtiment vert pour l'université de
winchester
c'est aussi une déclaration claire de notre
engagement
à la justice sociale durable
et à la lutte contre la crise climatique